[Musique]
l'automne dernier romain manger lorrain
a appris bien malgré elle les limites de
l'accessibilité à l'avortement en
gaspésie et ce même si elle réside à
gaspé la plus importante ville de la
péninsule
j'ai pris un test de grossesse positif
et moi je pensais que ça faisait
peut-être deux trois semaines même pas
un mois j'étais enceinte parce que j'ai
jamais arrêté d'avoir mes veille
pourtant l'échographie planifié avant
son avortement révèle qu'elle est
enceinte depuis quatre mois l'a
fortement agacé et accessible juste
avant 12 semaines de grossesse alors moi
je suis allé à l'extérieur de gaspé
bien que le territoire gaspésien s'étend
sur plus de 800 kilomètres de côtes seul
hôpital de gaspé offre l'avortement
chirurgical et le service n'est même pas
offert jusqu'à la fin du premier
trimestre de grossesse s'est offert à
gaspé clinique de planning de gaspé
chose que douze semaines et ses jours on
est capable par l'intervention à gaspé
comme tel ça prend une certaine
expertise avec nos petits volumes gaspé
et lassant de référence pour l'ensemble
du territoire l'option la plus proche
pour romane était donc de se rendre à
l'hôpital de rimouski un voyage de 9
heures aller retour elle a plutôt choisi
d'aller à québec ce qui représente 16
heures de route au total
mais même les gaspésienne qui ont la
possibilité de se faire avorter dans la
péninsule parcours souvent des centaines
de kilomètres celle qui réside à l'ouest
de la région doivent rouler entre 3 et 5
heures pour se rendre à gaspé ce n'est
pas pour rien que l'endroit est surnommé
le bout du monde
[Musique]
aux îles-de-la-madeleine malgré une
population six fois plus petite qu'en
gaspésie l'avortement chirurgical est
assurée jusqu'à 15 semaines et six jours
de grossesse après quoi les femmes
doivent prendre l'avion pour se faire
avorter à québec une réalité qui
s'applique à de nombreux autres soins de
santé spécialisés qui ne sont pas
offerts dans l'archipel
quand les services ne sont pas donnés
c'est facile qui lisait à la cades à
laquelle la capitale nationale ou
ailleurs là j'ai des gens qui vont à
montréal pour des examens chez des
spéciales il en est d'autres qui vont a
beaucoup qui vont à québec la distance
est notre plus gros enjeu en gaspésie la
table de concertation des groupes de
femmes gaspésie îles de la madeleine est
d'avis que toutes les femmes n'ont pas
un accès égal à l'avortement encore
faut-il qu'elles aient les moyens de se
déplacer car les remboursements offerts
par l'état ne couvrent souvent qu'en
partie les coûts réels d'un déplacement
y va vraiment cet enjeu la distance à
parcourir dans des frais de déplacement
peut-être prend congé au travail il ya
le mans peut-être de l'hébergement
l'accès est pas la même pour chacune
sait qu'à condamner moins se déplacer
c'est plus sain mais parfois c'est
vraiment pas le cas pour tout le 6 de la
gaspésie mise sur la pilule abortive
pour améliorer l'accès à l'avortement
sur le territoire et non sur
l'implantation du service chirurgical
dans d'autres hôpitaux depuis 2018 on
travaille plus tôt
déjà implanté un autre type
d'avortements l'avortement
inférieur de 9 semaines donc
l'avortement pas médicaments et c'est
plus cette option la fin de compte qu'on
ne travaille à l'heure actuelle pour
s'assurer que c'est bien ancrée dans
l'ensemble du territoire
le collège des médecins du québec
encadrent toutefois la prescription de
la pilule abortive de façon plus sévère
qu'ailleurs au canada entre 45 et 65
avortement ont lieu chaque année en
gaspésie moins de 20 % d'entre eux sont
faits par médicaments
[Musique]
mais au delà de l'accessibilité
géographique
un autre obstacle se dresse devant les
gaspésienne et majin yen qui souhaitent
interrompre leur grossesse
obtenir le service dans l'anonymat alors
dans un contexte insulaire c'est sûr que
peut-être que les difficultés sont
amplifiées parce que comme on est dans
un petit milieu je sais fait de devoir
réfléchir à ça et peut-être de partager
aussi sa réflexion ouvre la porte à bien
des peurs en force de celle de la
confidentialité celle aussi du jugement
de la stigmatisation aussi quand on est
dans un petit milieu au niveau de la
confidentialité savez une personne peut
avoir des appréhensions donc y en a qui
m'ont préféré se déplacer pour éviter de
croiser peut-être quelqu'un qu'on
connaît
romain danger lorrains espèrent que les
tabous entourant l'avortement vont
tomber et que les femmes n'auront plus à
se cacher pour recourir à ce service car
la route à emprunter pour interrompre sa
grossesse est déjà assez éprouvante
parce que
la famille a gardé quelques fois de
transport nécessairement ça peut être
parce que c'est quelque chose
autour de toi
malgré la distance parcourue romain n'a
pu se faire avorter comme elle le
désirait sans honte ni secret entourée
de sa famille mais elle sait que toutes
les femmes n'ont pas cette option ici il
avait la rose radio-canada gaspi